المزيد من المتابعه المدير الاقليمي
لجمعيات الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر
لمنطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
الدكتور حسام شرقاوي دكتور حسام اهلا
وسهلا
في اخر الجهود التي تقومون بها مع جميع
الاطراف سواء في عمليات الاغاثه او
الانقاذ او ارسال المساعدات العينيه الى
المحتاجين وماذا عن المعابر
اشكرك انا عدت امس بعد زياره ثلاث ايام
لسوريا اطلع على الوضع
والمعونات العينيه التي توصل بطائرات
يوميا من عده دول العربيه السعوديه
الامارات الكويت العراق
اردن مصر جزائر وغيره ايران
يتم سريعا
اخلاء الطائرات
وانا تابعت الشاحنات التي تعبئ وترسل الى
الشمال في مناطق فيها وضع امني حساس في
مناطق وصلتها المعونات وهذا يدور 24 ساعه
الوضع ماساوي كما كل التقارير تفيد وبدات
تظهر حجم الدمار
نحس الجميع انه نحط السياسه على جنب ونركز
على انقاذ الناس وتقديم المعونه
زملائنا في الهلال الاحمر العربي السوري
بحضروا القافره القافلات تتوجه يوم
الاثنين لمناطق ادلب
من داخل سوريا وليس من المعابر التي برضو
تاتي من تركيا وان شاء الله هذه المعونه
حتتوسع فيها
الوضع في تركيا برضه ماساوي والسلطات
التركيه طبعا
نتفهم تماما مبسلطين او مركزين دعمهم
للشعبهم ولاهلهم
انا متفائل خير اليوم سمعنا برضو اخبار
كويسه من حكومه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
برفع الحصار عن تحويلات الماليه لمده 180
يوم
لمساعده
اغاثه
المنكوبين من هذا الزلزال
نداءاتكم يعني كنت بلاش انت في الحديث انه
هذه استجابه
لنداءاتكم ولكن كيف تتاكدون من وصول هذه
المساعدات العينيه الى المحتاجين الى
الملهوفين الاله مثل هكذا مساعدات خصوصا
في سوريا نحن تعرف في سوريا يعني في قوه
فاعله هنا وقوه فاعله هناك هل من تنسيق
بين الاطراف لمرور هذه المساعدات خصوصا
الى الشمال السوري يعني منذ بعض الوقت قال
الصليب الاحمر انه بعبر باب الهوى دخلت
منه بعض
[موسيقى]
المساعدات وبالتنسيق مع الحكومه السوريه
انتم ما هي معلوماتكم
انا اليوم كان عندي لقاء مع كثير
المسؤولين في هذه الامم وشتى هيئاتها
لنزيد المعونات والنسق المعونات
نبعد عن الازدواجيه
لدينا اتحاد دولي للجمعيات الهلال الاحمر
والصليب الاحمر فرق موجوده دائما قبل
الزلزال داخل سوريا وتتابع بشكل يومي
وفوري توزيع المعونات فاحنا عنا قناعه
تامه على انه هذا يتم بالتركيز على حاجات
الناس طبعا المعونات اللي وصلت لحد الان
لا تكفي ابدا حجم
الاحتياجات
فمازلنا نطالب المجتمع الدولي
بالتبرع اكثر واكثر سواء
عينيا او سواء كاش
يساعدنا برضو بشراء بعض الامور داخل سوريا
لانه في بعض الشغلات البطانيات وغيره
الخيم ممكن نلاقيها داخل صوره وبدانا
بتنفيذ هذا مع الاحمر العربي السوري
فالمرحله هذه احنا بنحكي على ايام بعد
زلزالين ضخمين ضرب المنطقه اي دوله اي
دوله في العالم
مهما كانت قدراتها حتواجد صعوبه انها توجه
الدعم فوري للجميع بس انا عندي قناعه تامه
بعد زيارتي انه العمليه تمشي
على ما يرام طيب دكتور حسام بتعرف انه هذه
الماساه وهذه الفاجعه ستظل ارهاصاتها معنا
لاشهر وسنوات ما الذي تحتاجونه سواء يعني
في الايام المقبله في الاشهر المقبله في
السنه يعني وحتى في السنوات المقبله نحن
نتحدث عن مئات الالاف من المشربين بدون
ماوى ان نتحدث عن عشرات الالاف ربما من
الايتام من الاطفال طيب هؤلاء يعني انتم
الان هل لديكم خطه يعني وضعتم خطه الان
للتعامل مع هذه الارهاصات
اكيد تفضلت فيه بالزبط تجربتنا في كل
العالم هذا ليس اول زلزال كحركه دوليه
احنا نتعامل معه تعاملنا مع زلزالات ضخمه
في هيتي ونطال وباكستان وغيره
اليتامى واللي فقدوا
اطراف واللي حيحتاجوا دعم لسنوات لبناء
والعلاج النفسي اللي كتير فئات حتحتاجه
اعاده بناء وتاهيل بعض المستشفيات
والعيادات وغيره خططنا الان تطلب لسوريا
80 مليون دولار هدول تساعد
مرحله اولى 300 ل 400 الف شخص ممكن يزيدها
بملايين بننسقها مع الاخرين وخطتنا لمده
سنتين وممكن تكون لمده اكثر من هكذا حسب
الموارد والتمويل احنا بنعرف تماما انه
زلزال زي هذا التعافي منه سنوات وليس
اسابيع او اشهر
يعني نتمنى لكم كل التوفيق دكتور حسام في
هذه المهمه الانسانيه خصوصا في هذا الوقت
الحرج من بيروت المدير الاقليمي لجمعيات
الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر لمنطقه
الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا الدكتور عيسى
حسام شرقاوي شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المشاركه